hello welcome to this video and Lavrenti
that's a new opponent right yep so
playing a little bit more before you
five recently I want to really yeah I
get a little bit more practice with that
it's my standard reply of course to 1.e4
but still sometimes the field of
atrocity where some lines hmm I think
again Gustafson recently mentioned that
d3 would be the best move in this
position hmm d3 es6 take c to Queenie to
hmm should be six maybe it looks kind of
wild 94 is a standard standard move but
usually mr. Gustafson is very informed
about his openings so that probably is
right Bishop g5 looks a little bit
annoying him hmm yeah maybe I can still
go queen d 6 yeah well here I have Queen
def six so i don't really don't really
think that this can be that dangerous
what Bishop g5 I mean I can take g7 yeah
i think i just take g7 I was thinking
Queen f5 might also be an option going
for root g7 next ah so he tries to keep
it trust to keep the bishop down very
ambitious move
so castling law is a sacrifice couple of
interesting ideas
and the floor looks looks tempting yeah
I think I'm going for that if he castles
short I mean this is also going into the
G file no that's a surprising move I
mean doesn't that accelerate my play
quite a bit attacking b2f Queenie five
as possible moves so what now maybe
you're up to aite group d 8 Bishop g5
I've got Queenie 5 check yeah so I can
do the girl for that
and if he canceled short I take on c3
Quincy three teenage six so we cannot
castle short which is annoying however
he just castles law okay so let's not
exactly a move I've expected
the ship's III does not work maybe I
don't know that's a position where I
would love to have more time to really
figure it out very complicated I get I'm
threatening bishops III yeah here I've
got the chick but okay then hmm I can
also take there won't be too I mean
should be too when I probably move with
the King simply when Bishop f5 that's a
very very crazy position Jack hey let's
go for that I don't understand anything
I mean anything so if you move the King
to be one it's also the bishop you can
also check on 8 a-2 here and Queenie 6
check that wins the Queen but is it any
good the resulting position is certainly
very very crazy Bishop f5
I don't know one check it's two pieces
and the rook night eggs should be a 26-6
Jegs I cannot take this at the end and
his King is also exposed time Marcia I
cannot figure it out in that time I have
also look asics check now that I think
of it okay six check kingdom one okay
one King see two that's probably not
going to work and I have crook v6 check
however that is interesting I will be
six check pink see one just about who
also exactly taking this and our Bishop
takes I guess that that's what I'm
expecting no of course not so let's take
this check yeah he's got some checks but
I don't see anything brilliant TM I was
calculating until the other did Bishop
takes and I couldn't figure it out that
is was where I was taking so much time
of course they play something else and
this is not so critical
and GG seven hangs with check that's
also quite useful check getting rid of
that porn is really important so that
okay then drew q1 and better make sure
that i'm not back reg made it check
check this is check certainly useful
check so watch think I'm going to trade
it's nothing check it's no particular
reason not to trade the porn C are very
quick sometimes you want to keep a rock
on to to have more firepower Queen a
truck as an attacking force but it's not
relevant here I think as the pawns are
so dangerous on their own check
unfortunately it is not exactly
difficult to play you can just have to
push check check check check white
resigns yeah very very complicated stuff
you out of this opening yeah well it's a
it's a bit of a shirt I took took a long
time yet for playing be three maybe I
should have just trusted mr. Gustave
Sonia and play it they are ok txt chat
and the end you're just gives King f8
hmm sure it's not an easy move to play
if you don't know that it is that it is
playable something like this looks
somewhat tricky the engine just gives
this one
no ok this is I don't you about really
it's it's very very complicated when
there i was thinking Bishop g5 is more
critical ready but ok this this and now
yeah now i went deform still like the
move but it's tough to say this is also
making quite some sense there are some
ideas here also an idea for is also an
interesting idea that i didn't really
recognize I didn't really am a seam one
know when I was in the game check dennis
is a a version of the game let's same
that's good for black something like
this is just good for black and far far
more active and half the bishop pal okay
t4 and no he took it yeah this is losing
actually engine gives Queen g5 not the
most natural move ever so this is losing
long castles yeah you know I'm stupid I
didn't see Queen I only saw Queenie five
after I was thinking rook the a-10s aw
ok Bishop g5 I've got the check and this
is of course a much stronger version
with the King secure and the rook
protected by the rukon g8 here he has no
CS no moves actually this is the problem
this is a deadly threat if now castles
long i'll just take it he resigns this
game
now it's pretty simple i am ok and this
is now not clear at all I guess well the
engine will certainly give some good
evaluation if you give it some time to
calculate rook t6 is also given by the
engine so that was a good move 94 I took
and the computer gives queen takes
between not this one because of Bishop
f5 years or queen g60 I saw those moves
but I couldn't really figure it out and
then she decided to do this which wasn't
clear to me at all but the credit line
is quite obviously Bishop did too and
not 9292 is just kept blundering a piece
essentially and this position was the
one that gap wasn't clear to me because
here I mean material is about equal but
it's a complete mess and if I take here
he probably has really worn or bishops
III added wins in fact provide so engine
get something like this and yeah
currently shows 0.5 for what hmm
mm-hmm it's it's just a complete mess in
a blitz game i think i'd also rather be
white your king is open but White's
players simply is pretty simple root AG
one and yeah but yeah it was most
difficult difficult to to figure out
during the game yet after this he's just
changing and check it's nothing much
happening check it's just a material
loss so it's quite mysterious why it
took with the noid and did so okay took
10 seconds and hard to explain yeah what
was he seeing here of why I cannot see
again this is losing the Queen but
that's a very simple tactic I don't know
what here what you missed them okay
thanks for watching